ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
closing ceremony of the 2013
sink field cup it is my honor to present
to you the four competitors
gotta kamsky hikaru nakamura lavon
aronian
and magnus carlson
so we'll begin briefly uh with a
question and answer session
um so whenever i come by please make
sure you speak into the mic that way
everything gets recorded and we can put
it up online and
our spectators who aren't in st louis
can enjoy this as well
um if you would please just have your
question ready to go if it's for the
entire group
say so if it's for a specific person
please say that as well
so who'd like to kick it off what is our
first question for the four competitors
in the same field cup
hi this is mike klein with chess.com and
with chess life i'm curious for
any of the players that want to respond
uh how does a six round event
differ in in the way you play since most
of the events you guys play are so much
longer than six rounds
i think we should ask the most
experienced player here
i forgot when it was last time
so remember the u.s championship
2011 it was two eight player round
robins followed by a knockout afterward
so that was only seven rounds also of
similar length to this event
um and i remember people were saying you
know it was like a sprint right
you had to score your points early you
disagree not even close
yeah explain
well i took the last place i mean do you
want me to they want me to explain
you know ask the winners or something i
understand
does anybody else have an opinion on on
events of such
a few rounds doesn't
affect the way you play or well i think
the main thing with it
not in the length is that it's a double
round robin which is the biggest
difference between the tournament and
many others um
obviously we played each other two times
with white and black so
i think that's the huge difference like
in a nine-round tournament you're going
to play some people with white some
people it's black but when you play
everyone with both colors i think
it evens it out more and it's it's much
more fair but also since it's short
if you're not in form it can also be a
very difficult term
as god found out unfortunately thank you
very much
next question
question for magnus carlsen uh what are
your plans over the next
month or so before the world
championship
i don't know
rest uh not play anymore tournaments
um i don't know i think i think i'll um
i'll enjoy some rest over the next
couple of weeks and
i'll i'll have a
pretty long training session and then go
to india
it's obviously a big confidence boost to
win this event uh
with such a short amount of time between
this and your world championship match
um do you feel like you're you know at
your peak do you feel like you're
playing really well these days and do
you think that will carry over into the
match
uh i wouldn't say that i'm playing
really well
i think i played um
reasonably well uh of course the
the final margin of victory is is a bit
flattering but overall i'm
pretty satisfied with uh with my play
next question
this one's from magnus again um how did
you view this tournament in regards to
that upcoming
match did you hold anything back maybe
simply talking about that dutch defense
that you use haven't used in a long time
uh were you concerned at all about the
match coming up and
caused you to change anything today this
week
um no i think the dutch defense that was
more a result of being in a particularly
good mood
that day so
i think in general
in this tournament uh most of the games
were
decided over the board
um in the middle game and game in
complicated fights rather than
in in preparation so i don't think it
matters too much
lavon i have a question for you also um
you played last in the united states in
1999
las vegas as part of the world
championship cycle then
um how would you say your
memories of the united states compare
now that you've been here for a week and
seen st
louis i really enjoy being in the united
states so
i mean first time i came i was just a
little boy
and now i'm a bit older uh
i won't say that uh
that joy that i had here contributed to
my play
but other than that
you know i look forward coming back
next question
uh this is for hikaru numerically in a
performance rating point of view
you had a really good tournament but are
you satisfied with the tournament
um well i think anytime you pick up
rating points uh
generally it's a good good way of
determining
how you did overall uh if you'd asked me
before the turn if i'd be happy with uh
plus one having you know one
one more game um then i lost i i would
have said yeah i'd be happy with it
uh considering the way the tournament
started it's a bit of a disappointment
but still
i mean okay i performed better better
than my rating so by any numerical
standard it's a good result
next question
okay this question is especially from
magnus and levon but
also the other players if they want to
reply
do you think it's beneficial for chess
that um
there are tournaments held in the united
states if this
spreads around and so top class
tournament are played here
and what's your experience especially
magnus since you're
it's the first time you play top events
here
i think it's very good um
when you have new top level tournaments
uh where the conditions are are
good good for the for the players
um the spectators are are taken well
care of
everything is running well um
regardless of whether it's the in the
united states or or elsewhere and uh
i'm i'm very happy with
the way i've been treated here i think
all of all of the players are and
i hope the spectators and
and organizers are happy as well
thank you very much anybody else have
anything to add to that
okay next question
i wasn't talked about much i'm just
curious if the players
thought that it was a little bit of a
usa against the world and tabulating
scores and if
that's something that all you guys had
thought of it hasn't been asked of any
of you i don't think so
i'm curious if any of you thought about
that
uh i don't think in general it felt like
it was the us against the world thing i
think for me
personally the main thing was that i
felt more comfortable here than i
than i do in europe generally um there
are more fans here who are rooting for
me so i felt like that certainly
gave me more motivation and good reason
to to try and win every game um
so just in general that's the main thing
because i know both lavon and magnus
when
when they uh when they play tournaments
pretty much anywhere they're very
they're very popular and well-known i
can't say the same as uh
true for either myself or god so that's
probably the main thing that i
i found that was nice about being being
american and playing a tournament here
especially in st louis
well there is a connotation a little bit
here but
um since it's not really a team event
it's more individualized but um i i like
the comparison though it was like
it was really nice like that
yeah thank you next question
this is for the two out of towners uh
what do you what
what are your thoughts on the st louis
chess club
um i'm very happy with with everything
apart from apart from
the end of my game with gata where there
were some
people playing music over the street
which i thought was really annoying
so uh if you
if you have a banner in the next
tournament
uh that says no music within within a
mile or something i will be
right i'll be very very happy to come
back every
chess game needs a theme song lavon what
would you take
it's a beautiful club and
you know i was not expecting to see so
many people to come and watch every day
it was very eye pleasing
so
i hope the interest in san luis will
grow
after this tournament and there will be
many more
beautiful events of this one to follow
so it's been said by
quite a few people actually that the
very top level chess the elite chess
that you
all play um has become less and less
about
natural ability over the board you
versus your opponent
and more about preparation kind of the
scientific approach to chess
memorization study of the game
what do you see as the future of chess
over the next 10 or 15 years
and do you think that the uh the fact
that computers are becoming stronger and
stronger at chess
will have an impact on the game when
played between humans
i think we've been we've been talking
about
uh the draw death of chess ever since
the days of
of uh capablanca and aliyakin and
i think it's it's not here yet but by
any means
so there will always be some some games
decided on the opening without
any any um moves really being made
over the board but as you see in in this
tournament
and i feel like in most tournaments i
take part of anybody
um it it's really all about fighting
chess still and
uh that's very good to see and i think
there's also been
bit of a trend towards that the last few
years
there were some um
linares tournaments i mean 10
years ago about which were really
um not that interesting or
it was interesting but very very drawish
but i think recently it's
it's it's all it's all fighting chess
i know that that people have often um uh
observe the fact that kramnik for
example
um you know he's been uh dusting off
openings that haven't been played for a
long time
uh that were supposed to be bad for
black especially and with the help of
computers and analysis
he says look the position's solid and it
may look uncomfortable but it's just
fine
do you think that that mindset has
impacted your chess
i don't think kramnik plays many search
positions
i can't remember him playing playing
like that so
he usually plays uh he usually plays
quite
actively
anybody have anything else to add to
that
i mean all i'm gonna say is that um okay
i think lavon probably would agree with
this too in fact but um
i mean the problem with trust in general
is it there there are a lot of draws and
there are a lot of positions now that
are
i mean when you look at them with
computers they're just very equal um
and while i still do enjoy classical
chess a lot i mean i've
always been a fan of fischer random and
okay i actually prefer it in general
okay thank you next question
question to magnus again yeah
annan said that preparing for a world
championship is different
than preparing for a tournament
do you agree with this and if so what
changing
in your training and in your routine if
if any and if this tournament was part
of your training
how you benefited from it
um i am i do believe that
um training for the world championship
is a little bit
uh different from other tournaments but
it it's also
true that if if something's working for
you you shouldn't
change it too much um
and uh as as for this tournament
i think it's been uh it's been a good
uh very good experience for me also as
us as training for
for the world championship uh because um
for me not playing a tournament since
the last time i played in
in tall memorial in in june till now
would be would be just a bit long and i
would
risk being being rusted there but here
uh
um i i was at a lot of challenges
uh for instance today i think was
was um was much of the same
kind of pressure situation that
will i think occur in a world
championship match
thank you very much uh dirk
um one for magnus um it's not a big
secret that you don't like to get up too
early
here the um the rounds they started at
one but on the other hand there was a
seven hour difference with
norway did you feel that you were
playing early in the evening
and if so did that help you
i didn't think too much about that i
felt that i had a
pretty healthy sleeping rhythm here
and i didn't need to get up
any earlier today really than i
i did the other days nevertheless i was
feeling a little bit sluggish today at
the start i don't know why but
i didn't think about it maybe it's uh
maybe it's
a bit of a factor i don't know okay
we'll have two final questions here
and then we will go on from there
uh when you reach this level of chess
play
do you guys play for fun anymore and if
so
do you play a computer or do you have
someone in particular that you enjoy
playing chess with
not a trick question
okay i guess i'll answer this one um in
general i don't think we play for fun
but all of us every so often we do
exhibitions or
simultaneous um well simultaneous
exhibitions and
uh that then it is somewhat fun i mean i
know for me personally i i don't
play for fun as kind of training per se
but you know when i do have the chance
um
i do do like just playing for fun every
so often here at the club with uh
regulars or also when i'm in europe
sometimes with with little kids so
it's it's just doing something fun i
mean trust of course it's been great to
all of us so it's good to give back
sometimes
okay and our final question
occasionally we read about people who
may be
cheating or are cheating at chess not
quite at your level
but what i'm what i'm wondering is are
you worried that somebody
very high rated 2700 feet a plus will
eventually start to cheat and it won't
be noticeable because
they'll be 27.50 then they're 28 20 like
oh they got better
and have you do you think fide should do
anything
about what seems to be a plethora of
incidents where people may be cheating
to
with with computers and glasses and ear
things and all that kind of stuff and
have you encountered any of that kind of
stuff
i mean that's such a difficult question
we couldn't even answer easy ones so
yeah but generally i mean now i'll take
this one i
i think
nobody who becomes a good player
you know has that kind of character to
do that
you know it's just it's just respectful
towards the game
and most of us we love the game of chess
and
you can't become strong and and then be
a cheater
you'll be a cheater in the start and
then
it's easier to to see that you are but
in general i think the problem is
we're talking about that too much
because i think there's
maybe zero one one percent of people
who would ever have uh
enough moral
ground to do that you know most of us
are
we love the game and we're distant human
beings
i'd like to thank the players for uh for
being so candid in their replies
um i know that these will show up in all
of the chess periodicals and websites uh
probably still this evening
um and
one of the reasons why we host these big
events at the chess club is basically
that
spotlighting the very best whether
they're the very best american players
or the best overall or
or you know from anywhere creates
or or showcases the role models uh for
small children all too often uh you have
little kids that look up to their
baseball or their football or their
basketball heroes um and while that
is also an important part of one's
character
it's also nice to see individuals who
are
famous who are celebrities of sorts
for being intellectual for using their
brains so
by hosting these events our goal is to
ultimately
introduce the game to as many students
as possible and let them know that
that they have other options you know
they don't just have to become a rap
star
or a basketball player or a baseball
player you know they can
become a chess player and then join us
here at the chess club
so i think we need just a couple of
minutes uh from our
camera folks uh and then we will
continue with the rest of our awards
ceremony
so if you can just be with us for maybe
two or three minutes we'll be ready to
go soon
you have a good chest joke
barnes and noble here in st louis and i
would go on wednesdays after school and
set up our little folding tables and i
would set out our coffee can for
donations
and eventually we'd collect enough
change that i'd be able to buy a new
chess set for the club or maybe a new
clock if i was really doing well
and little did i know that um that this
is really what could happen with chess
here in st louis
um st louis is quickly becoming known as
the destination for chess in the united
states and hopefully around the world
with events like this i want
uh linares vikanze all of the other
names
or cities that you think of uh in the
chess world i want st
louis to be included as part of that and
again thanks to the the generosity and
the vision and the dedication
of of rex and genie uh were here today
so it is without further ado that i'm
happy to introduce our founder rex
sinfield
thank you tony first of all i want to
start off by introducing a frequent
visitor
to our big chess events the mayor of st
louis the honorable francis slay
well first of all good evening everyone
and to the players
welcome to st louis i've met a couple of
you before
uh but to to have you here at the uh
chess club and scholastic center in st
louis is a thrill
and an honor what this organization has
done for our city
is something that is very difficult to
describe but we are
we consider ourselves and we've been uh
named the chess city of america and
we're very very proud of it as tony
rich was saying that uh you know we with
the with the
support and the vision of uh rex and
jennings
genie singfield uh we we want to do more
as a city in that regard
this is an incredible event as i
understand at the highest
rated event chess event in st
louis or in the united states of america
so that's something we're very very
proud of and certainly we wouldn't be
here
with this if we didn't have these
talented players who agreed to come
and participate so on behalf of the
people of st louis
we're thrilled to have you here uh we're
honored to have you in our city
and uh certainly want to congratulate
all of you in your successes in chess
and certainly are looking to uh to watch
you as you as you go further
uh with chess nationally and
internationally as well
so i wish you all the very very best but
to all the guests that are here from out
of town
um it's always a thrill to have you here
and as i said uh with this quality
organization
uh we're very very proud to uh be
uh you know really a player nationally
and and internationally in the chess
world
and we want to continue to be so thank
you genie uh and thank you rex and
certainly
look forward to some more great events
in the future
thank you thank you mr mayor there are
so many people to thank i don't know
where to begin but i have to begin
somewhere
so first of all did we not have the best
commentators in the history of chess
and then to joy bray and tony rich and
all of their associates they did an
amazing
job organizing and running this event
thank you so much
all of you
and i of course especially want to thank
the players
and for being so accommodating of all of
your fans
you know that's quite a burden the way
they crowd you but i saw how generously
you gave
of your time and we thank you very much
for that
uh how ironic in this city which all
americans know is the greatest sports
city
in the united states it has it has that
name
and next door at leicester's the best
sports bar in saint louis
yesterday the manager said he has never
seen the place so full
and what caused it but not a football or
baseball game but a chess match
what a wonderful thing and i'm also
delighted that
magnus and lavonne got to go to a
baseball game and i hope you understand
how important it is
that you go back to your countries and
tell your governments that baseball
should be your national sport
so jeannie you will come up we'll
present the
trophy
so magnus carlson
our honor and privilege to present you
with this first single field cup
congratulations
okay yeah thank you okay thank you like
to say a couple words
here so you can talk no
um
i don't have too much time i'd like to
thank uh rex
and and and ginny uh again
uh for uh for a wonderful tournament and
um
if everything uh goes well i'll be uh
i'll be back
yes thank you i will say now that you've
been to st
louis you know where it is and you know
how to get here we expect you to come
back frequently and lavon also
and uh just one more thing i uh
i um i do not necessarily uh
agree on the whole uh whole baseball
thing
um but it's always interesting to see a
game that
resembles chess at least a little bit
so as i alluded to before make sure you
stay tuned for
uh uh maybe 11 months or so from now
um i am proud to announce to you that we
will be hosting the
2014 sink field cup here at the chess
club and scholastic center as well
so in closing i would like to thank you
all once again for joining us
i'm sure that the players have enjoyed
seeing all of their fans and all of the
reporters
and making sure that the brilliancies
that they have
have demonstrated over the chessboard
have reached the masses
i want to thank all of our spectators
obviously it's because of you that the
event was so successful there's a real
electricity in the air real
uh a real feel of competition and i
would challenge anyone who says that
chess is not a sport to come enjoy one
day
of commentary and watching the
competitors and finally i would like to
thank the players without them this
event would have been possible thank you
all very much
you